a woman is suing a valley senior living
facility after she says her brother died
under their watch her lawyer says 56
year old andrew louis walked out and was
found dead on the street now his family
is speaking out today hoping to get
justice
it's never easy my life has changed a
grim reality that christine lowe says
will forever haunt her during the
pandemic her 56 year old brother andrew
developed dementia and lowe says she did
all she could to care for him i still
keep him at home until i said
this is getting too much full he would
get up in the middle of the night
playing with the water he would flush
the toilet
20 times a day that's when the bay area
residents seeked help and found pacifica
senior living in green valley their
website stating the safety of you and
your loved ones is our top priority an
ideal sight she says since her brother
was known to wander within less than 48
hours of him being at the facility he
escapes and the reason it happened is
because they put him in the wrong
facility they're supposed to put him in
the lock facility according to henderson
police officers were dispatched on
august 20 2021 to bermuda and volunteer
road and found a man deceased in the
desert area he matched the description
of a missing asian male from a nearby
senior living facility coroner's report
stated the man had died from heat stress
with dehydration with an additional
condition of dementia lowe says she was
notified a short time later of what
happened i was just heartbroken to say
the list i couldn't
i was crying
all day all night now low seeks justice
with this lawsuit in hopes this will
never happen again before my mom passed
she told me to take care of him
we reached out to pacifica senior living
for comment on this case and as of now
they have not provided a response